deux cérémonies pour le prix du nez hier
mercredi la chambre des métiers et de
l'artisanat des yvelines a révélé les
lauréats du concours de l'entreprise
numérique des yvelines et ceux de stars
et métiers deux opérations dont le but
est de valoriser le dynamisme de ses
acteurs de l'emploi bonsoir daniel
varlet je vous ai dit le président de la
chambre des métiers de l'artisanat dans
le département bonsoir olivier ledoux l
échange et le directeur de verre déco
l'une des sociétés lauréates ces
différents prix on va en parler à tout à
l'heure
installé à magny les hameaux vous
intervenez dans le domaine de la
conception à la réalisation de
l'entretien au suivi des jardins
intérieurs comme extérieurs et tout ça
dans le respect de l'environnement de
l'écologie
daniel verlet je le disais tout à
l'heure le but c'est de valoriser le
dynamisme de l'encourager en tout cas le
dynamisme de ses artisans
absolument nous avons toujours plaisir à
mettre à l'honneur nos artisans et
viennois et au travers de ces deux
concours on récompense les artisans les
plus dynamiques
ce que voulait montrer c'est que l'image
qu'on peut avoir de l'artisanat dépassé
n'a plus lieu d'être aujourd'hui les
artisans sont rentré de plain pied dans
cette époque et les artisans n'ont
jamais été dépassés ils ont toujours été
en à la pointe du progrès et là c'est
plutôt sur des technologies bien
spécifique pour montrer jusqu'où va la
l'artisanat dans nos métiers parce qu'il
ya ce prix justement du concours de
l'entreprise numérique
alors ça correspond à quoi ce sont des
entreprises qui interviennent dans ce
domaine là où qui utilisent ces outils
pour valoriser leur travail a lancé dès
des entreprises alors initialement le
le le concours était mise en place
depuis 2002 à 2008 pour d'abord aider
les entreprises à se doter d'équipements
informatiques
ce prix a été doté par le conseil
général ensuite on a un petit peu
modifié et c'est pour ça que depuis deux
ans c'est le concours de l'entreprise
numérique
c'est pour mettre en avant les
entreprises qui se servent de l'outil
informatique et au travers de l'outil
informatique qu'ils puissent progresser
au niveau de leur activité artisanale le
travail de la chambre des métiers c'est
aussi d'accompagner ces entreprises de
les guider de leur apprendre à utiliser
ses outils
alors on bien sûr qu'on les aide dans
tout aussi bien dans leurs installations
que dans le cheminement de l'entreprise
et
la chambre de métiers par le service
économique est toujours à leurs côtés
suivant leurs demandes et leurs besoins
c'est aujourd'hui indispensable
d'utiliser tous ces outils numériques
pour développer son activité
absolument si on leur corps vu hier par
la démonstration des lauréats qui
étaient là et l'informatique et
l'artisanat scellier scellier de pair et
c'est cette incroyable
les besoins en informatique l'artisanat
il y avait deux concours deux cérémonies
de remise de prix
hier dans vos locaux le concours
également stars et métiers alors
expliquez nous ce concours un peu plus
en détail ce qu'il récompense alors
stars et métiers c'est une institution
déjà depuis de nombreuses années en
partenariat avec les banques populaires
selon mais vraiment le en excellence le
les artisans dans l'innovation
technologique ou la stratégie
d'innovation ou aussi la gestion de la
gestion de ressources humaines
au travers de ce concours met donc en
avant tout les entreprises les plus
performantes
et justement le lauréat de cette
catégorie dynamiques en matière de
gestion de ressources humaines c'est la
société vers d'écossé votre entreprise
qu'est ce qui la distingue justement
dans sa gestion des ressources humaines
de ses collaborateurs on essaye de
travailler de développer l'entreprise
vraiment avec toute une équipe et je
pense que cette cohésion est importante
et permet de développer économiquement
l'entreprise quels sont les outils
concrets que vous mettez en place
racette choses très simples on dire
basiques comme des réunions
hebdomadaires entre collaborateurs du
matin même secteur mais aussi des
réunions mensuelles avec l'ensemble
de tous les salariés pour voir un peu
comment on peut travailler mieux
améliorer un petit peu le fonctionnement
d'entreprise mais aussi des choses un
petit peu différente comme la notation
de l'encadrement par les salariés chaque
année et puis des outils informatiques
qui permettent de simplifier le travail
de chacun
l'idée c'est aussi d'éviter les tâches
répétitives c'est ce que vont me disait
quand on prévoit là on essaie on à en
équiper de 10pts toutes nos
collaborateurs sont équipés d'ipad et
par exemple les bons de passage quand on
va entretenir les jardins chez les
particuliers ou les entreprises signent
les bons de passage sur leopard et donc
transmettre les informations directement
en entreprise comme cela on aurait pu
imaginer votre entreprise recevoir un
autre prix parce que vous êtes plutôt
portée vers l'environnement vers
l'écologie avec justement ces
différentes technologies on peut
peut-être rappeler justement le l'objet
de l'activité principale de verre déco
voilà on est jardinier avant tout
intérieur tous qui plante d'intérieur
entretien des végétaux notamment surtout
on de l'entreprise et puis jardin
extérieur où on travaille pour
l'entretien des jardins et la conception
des jardins
on a un bureau d'études qui permet de
d'étudier l'ensemble de nos réalisations
et puis on a une activité de production
ont produit 80 mille plants pour notre
propre activité
on pourrait aussi faire un point sur
votre activité parce que pour ceux qui
nous suivent depuis longtemps sur
téléphiles on était venu vous voir il ya
quelques années déjà que l'installation
aujourd'hui comment se porte vers d'écho
dans la presse qui a trouvé ses marques
plus que ses marques puisqu'on a bien on
s'est bien développée ces dernières
années
l'année dernière on a fait une
profession à près de 10% d'augmentation
du chiffre d'affaires on a embauché une
dizaine de personnes l'année dernière
donc on se développe plutôt bien on est
dans un secteur qui porter très
concurrentiel mais porteur et puis on a
une image qui très très environnementale
d'eau qui est un petit peu dans le le
fil du temps on entendu le témoignage
donc du lauréat d'un des lauréats de
cette année
star et star et métiers sur la gestion
de ressources humaines quel est le jury
qui a décidé comment est composée jury
et puis quels sont les critères qui ont
été retenus alors le jury est composé
donc 2
d'acteurs économiques de la chambre de
métiers il est composé aussi d'artisans
et il est composé de nos partenaires
delà de la banque populaire
donc les critères les critères de
sélection sont définis c'est un système
de production de relations humaines
c'est suivant les dossiers que qui nous
sont apportés conjugent indépendamment
les uns des autres et après on met nos
résultats en commun et de la saur le
lauréat le prix pour vous c'est un
aboutissement ou c'est un encouragement
pour faire encore mieux pour moi c'est
un encouragement c'est pas un
aboutissement on en pleine mutation
change beaucoup de choses de chaque
année et donc c'est aussi un marqueur
pour dire non à un moment donné on était
plutôt bon il faut le rester voilà qu'à
faire autant et entend le rester et il y
aura d'autres étapes parce que là
c'était une étape régionale
absolument
monsieur baudoin elle va être enfin va
être son dossier va être monté au niveau
national et on espère bien sûr se
retrouver au niveau national fin
décembre pour free style primé au niveau
national les avis de nos collègues
artisans
je reviens à ce qu'on disait au début de
cette émission le but c'est de valoriser
de mettre en avant le dynamisme de
l'artisanat si on fait un petit état des
lieux donc département des yvelines
l'artisanal et ses différents métiers se
porte bien
les chiffres du chômage qui viennent de
tomber à 18 heures si vous nous suivez
en direct 3,2 millions de demandeurs
d'emploi en pour le mois de mars
donc tous les records ont été battus sur
ces vingt trente dernières années à côté
de ça l'artisanat se porte comme en bas
écoutez c'est nous sommes des gens qui
prenons le positif malgré que la crise
est quand même ressenti notamment
beaucoup au niveau du bâtiment
néanmoins
on est des gens qui embauchent ou encore
on cherche pas si vous savez qu'on a des
secteurs encore qu'ils ne sont pas
pourvus et dans nos dans nos entreprises
nous embauchent ou encore des
collaborateurs sans problème et
travailler dans le secteur de
l'artisanat c'est quand même l'ascenseur
social et ça laisse quand même des
portes ouvertes et pourquoi pas des
jeunes de pouvoir après reprendre nos
entreprises donc on est mal faire
véritablement carrière faire carrière
dans tout l'est à tous les étages et
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment dommage
qu'on ne puisse pas avoir le
collaborateur en nombre tel qu'on en a
besoin dans nos entreprises vous
embaucher pour faire des cô tes dents
bien sûr je confirme on a on a souvent
des demandes et puis en face on n'a pas
forcément les cv ou les personnes m dans
nos entreprises ce sera la bonne
nouvelle avec les chiffres du chômage
qui ne sont pas bons 3,2 millions de
demandeurs d'emploi pour le mois de mars
mais vous embaucher dans vos différents
secteurs voilà c'était un petit peu un
petit clin d'oeil face à la morosité qui
s'installe forcément merci à tous les
deux je rappelle ces cérémonies de prix
de l'entreprise numérique de stars et
métiers aussi vers déco qui reçoit le
prix régional dans la catégorie
dynamiques en matière de gestion de
ressources humaines l'entreprise est
basée à magny les hameaux merci à vous